because I was just walking the beach I  was walking the beach even if it's a  touristy area what I'm saying is some  countries like even just say when I go  Bangladesh and I'm not a tourist yeah  and I'm in my own country clothes  everything guys will still feel like  they can they have a right to come and  speak to you okay okay  yeah yeah I'm not saying it's wrong I'm  saying again look at social cues if like  you said the guys teaching girls what  signaling is if she's not making eye  contact if she's not don't maybe don't  approach her especially and that's how  they make guys  do you see how this is kind of like the  situation that I was describing because  you're kind of like me tooing these guys  because they approached okay